foreign
let's go to Preston who joins us now in
Dallas Texas Preston how can we help
hey how's it going Ken thank you thank
you all for having me this morning sure
uh I you know I'm a a married guy with
three kids uh we got a good income of
about 185 190 000 a year but it seems
like we are hemorrhaging money through
our miscellaneous budget item and our
our
food items
um you know we've got one car loan we've
got about twelve thousand dollars left
on that I've got some medical debt we
had a child this year so we've got about
six thousand dollars there
and then we've got uh just some student
loans left over uh that amount to about
4 500 and then a mortgage that's about
200 000 left so total debt is about 222
thousand dollars uh we make you know 185
190 and it feels like at the end of the
month we just have nothing left
um I really just kind of wanted to get
some insight on what should a family
spend uh you know monthly in a
miscellaneous item uh maybe in in the
food budget but we're just spending
pretty much what we earn and you know
we've gone up in salaries over the last
five years
tremendously we've doubled what we make
but we're still spending everything we
make and so I cannot figure out how to
get over that hump yeah it's uh it's the
classic lifestyle creep right it's just
a little bit here and there and over
time that starts to become your norm and
then you just add a little bit more add
a little bit more and then you look up
and you're exactly yeah what you're
saying
um president are you guys doing a very
detailed budget
very detailed I am in accounting which
is kind of ironic that I'm not good at
accounting for my own expense expenses
uh but you know we we set a food budget
of let's say 1500 to 2000 a month and
then you sit there and go hey we just
spent three thousand dollars on food uh
and you sit there and go how are we
doing that well uh as as George would
would like to not hear we eat out all
the dang time yeah that's it I mean
yeah yeah let's just let's go out to eat
it's easier I know and we all know that
that we're going to spend way more there
than we do at home but yeah it's really
just frustrating to be
well there's no that's what's hard about
this Preston is with personal finance we
always say it's it's 80 Behavior it's 20
head knowledge so you have the head
knowledge of the numbers down with the
budget of here's what we're gonna do but
then you guys are not living on the plan
that you've created you're going over a
thousand dollars in food you're throwing
you know a few hundred bucks here or
there throughout the month on all this
other stuff
um and so when you when you realize that
it's more of a discipline problem with
you guys and the choices that you're
making in everyday expenses it is it's
stuck in the the life out of out of
y'all what I would do Preston I would
challenge you guys
to say
um and you know if you hold on the line
I'm going to give you uh the premium
version of every dollar because I think
every dollar is one of the most helpful
budgeting tools because it's going to be
able to connect to your bank and you're
going to be able to really be able to
see in the way they do the paycheck
planning and everything it's just it's a
it's a really well easy thing to see and
your wife can have the same login so you
guys both have the app on your phone
and I would practice Preston acting like
you guys make 80.
okay act like you're like you're making
80 Grands and do a budget off of that
and just see what see what happens say
okay we then that means we have to way
cut back here that means these you know
18 subscriptions we're paying for we
can't do that uh that means maybe the
kids that are doing the fun Little Gym
classes every two days a week they're
not going to do that anymore like you
will have to cut back because I want you
to take that 80 grand or more quote
unquote I'm kind of just using a random
number but I want you pay enough the
student loan the car loan I mean all
these loans that you guys have beside
your mortgage you guys could get this
knocked out so quickly and what I love
about this we always just call it
gazelle intents because it is deep
sacrifice you are running like your hair
is on fire and it's like it is scorched
Earth it's like we're doing nothing
we're doing nothing and we're cutting
back and so that means maybe even
cutting back more than 80. I was just
saying as a fun mathematical game on the
budget just look to see what you would
cut start there and then I would trim
back as as much as you guys can Preston
because I want you guys to feel progress
with your money and it feels like you're
spinning your wheels you got all this
debt hanging around your living still
paycheck to paycheck and there's been no
progress and so in order to get these
wins like there's some stuff in
lifestyle that you will cut and it'll
hurt it will not be fun and I know with
a new baby it's like you guys are all
exhausted I get it that this is the time
to do it to buckle down and say it's now
or never it's for a short period of time
because then when all that's gone
Preston I mean how much is going out in
payments for this debt per month besides
your mortgage do you have that how much
is going out just to debt
I do uh so for our medical debt we
actually we've got a a high deductible
insurance plan so we've got an HSA that
I've got that set up to to wipe that out
in the year uh to where you know that
doesn't hang around so that's
automatically off the top and then we've
got my last car loan uh that we pay
about 2500 a month on it holy crap what
kind of car is it you're taking some
chunks up there oh you're paying extra
you're paying extra oh okay it's only
500 bucks okay okay
I think we've got more in the budget uh
but
you know we just once we get to the end
of the month to to make an extra payment
uh it's not there and it's just super
frustrating
yeah I mean it's because you're living
like you're making 190 and spending
everything yeah so let's just look at
this what's your what's the smallest
debt that you have
uh that'd be the the uh the student
loans uh you know we've got three of
them for the Sallie Mae loans but they
total about 4 500 bucks okay so instead
of focusing on the twelve thousand
dollar car loan focus on the student
loan yeah and go ahead and just get that
knocked out what's the payment what's
the minimum payment on the student loan
right now the three of them together
you all know they're in forbearance so
we haven't even been paying on them
we've been just chunking at her car
loans and I know that's not what baby
step two is uh for that gazelle
intensity okay
here's a point I'm trying to make if you
stay with us if you stay with us and you
work this plan you guys cut first of all
you need to stop eating out like no more
like you guys got to stop you gotta get
turkey sandwiches at night get do eggs
and bacon for dinner I mean like you can
do cheap meals right for a season it's
not forever you're a you're an
accountant your issue is not the numbers
the issue is the behavior and if you
guys try it for one month and go you
know what we're all in we're not going
to eat out one time at all just to see
how much money you can save extra
and the point is we knock out the
student loans then we knock out the
carpet and all of a sudden you've got
more margin than you realize here's the
I know you're discouraged but you've got
more margin in that budget than you
realize but you've got to change your
spending habits and if you do that and
if we can get some extra income we sell
some stuff in this debt snowball
whatever we got we can find margin
pretty quickly it's as detailed As You
Are
grasping the numbers you and your wife
have got to sit down and go if we do
this and then we do this and we do this
like crazy for the next six 12 months
here's how much progress we'll make and
then all of a sudden you go oh this is
doable I think you're just discouraged
right now and Preston with with I'll add
on that for Ken because this is always
helpful for me whenever we're doing a
big goal so whether for you it's getting
out of debt or you know it's saving up
for something look at the time frame run
the numbers like what we're saying and
just know and say okay we are confident
you know it's July right now so we are
confident you know by dang Christmas
we're gonna be we're gonna do it from
now till Christmas it's just it's go
time or whatever the the date is but
have that date because that gives you
the the light at the end of the tunnel
that you're not going to like live in
this world forever and ever amen you can
actually enjoy what you're working but
you're not enjoying your money now
because again I think so much of it is
this debt and so much of it is that
lifestyle because once you guys pay this
off do you have any savings at all
Prestons do you guys have cash in the
bank
yeah we have some but not enough to to
cover any of it how much
we've got our emergency fund just to
start emergency funds okay she got a
thousand dollars that's where you're at
yeah can you sell your wife's car
we get we're running out of time but I
mean you got to look at everything man
selling cars everything you know you're
gonna reduce your monthly payments and
increase your income so for you my
friend I know you're an accountant but
there's a lot of gig work right now for
accountants I'd be working 60 80 hours a
week doing accounting work because you
can get paid very well for freelance
work income goes up expenses go down
that's good enough to talk quick like
get after it and then you'll see some
breathing room and then you realize okay
we can stay the course